hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
within his discussion of the emotion of
anger in rhetoric book two aristotle is
going to highlight
a very important dynamic that i think we
can all
more or less relate to
from our own experience whether it's
that of getting angry ourselves
or that of observing other people
getting angry within our relationships
our culture
and it has to do
with
things being put down things being
insulted things being belittled not so
much
people
but
things that are not
themselves you could say
animate
having feelings all of those sorts of
things that goes with personhood and
remember that in the definition of anger
aristotle said that it's a desire for
retaliation based on some apparent
sliding
and the sliding has to be against
ourselves or you know oneself or against
those one
cares for literally those that are one's
own now it doesn't have to be
people or even
animals it could be
abstractions as we're going to see
or anything fitting into the domain
of
fandom or activities anything that we
take
seriously so what is this dynamic he
tells us people get angry with those who
and then he tells us two different
things and these kind of overlap to a
certain extent people who speak ill of
cacos lagusin in greek cacos is is this
general badly badness right as an as an
adverb and then legucine is the the verb
to to talk
or people who despise cataphronusi
and this is you know cataphronesis one
of the main modes of sliding that
aristotle
has distinguished along with spite
aperasmos and
insult hubris right so why is he picking
this one out
in particular to highlight couldn't it
be enough just to insult or get things
in the way of
why focus so much on contempt or
despising or literally thinking downward
upon
something and then what does speaking
ill include it could include the other
forms of
sliding it could also include things
like
getting matters mixed up or wrong i
remember when i was a kid
you know a teenager yeah very young
teenager and i was getting into dungeons
and dragons and my you know originally
francophone mother she's you know a
fourth generation immigrant but grew up
speaking french before english
would often reverse the things and would
call it dragons and dungeons and i would
get mad at her for saying that because i
felt it was a kind of unseriousness or
when my grandfather would come and i'd
have these tabletop role-playing games
that were very complicated and he'd come
by and he'd say who's winning
i'd get mad at him because i felt like
he was
speaking badly or showing contempt now
what do we
what do we get worked up about when it
comes to this things
that
people take
seriously in in the greek it's periha
malista
spudadzuccin so
is coming from spudayos which means
a serious person a person who is
committed sometimes it's a
adjective that means a good person or at
least a person who's serious about
ethics and morality but you could be
serious about all sorts of other things
ranging from a beautiful lawn to
your ability to cook amazing meals like
those that you see on tv
to celebrities and knowing everything
about them or sports you know statistics
or things like anything that a person
can take seriously
could become the object of this dynamic
and very interestingly aristotle gives
us two examples and then you know it
includes at the end of this discussion
one of those catch all
ki epi tone alone and you know with
respect to all the other kinds of things
like this as well so
the
universe of matters that we can take
seriously in this way and people can
talk badly about or denigrate uh and
then we can get angry about is pretty
limitless and it keeps getting added to
the more and more that we
learn
so what are the examples well this is
really quite interesting the first
example that aristotle gives
is his own profession
philosophy philosophy
in greek
the other thing that he talks about is
personal
appearance idea right so your your look
you could say and think about how
people do
get worked up about oh your your stuff
is out of style it's from last season oh
you know i'm being retro
people get very uh defensive about that
sort of thing
and
it's interesting to see that most of the
translations
um use the locution in english taking
pride in which i think does
somewhat capture the greek term philo to
muntai
right and so this is the word that is
associated with um
ambition or
literally loving honor or social status
filo means loving or being affiliated
with you know having an affinity with
and then to muntai team
is honor or social status and so these
are the things that we strive to
distinguish ourselves in to have you
could say a social role in so if it's
philosophy
it could be that you've studied a bit of
philosophy and you want to you know
appear
smart or you want to appear
knowledgeable or insightful
or well informed when it comes to it you
want other people to see you that way
and so when somebody else comes along
and says you know philosophy is just a
bunch of sophistry and it's a waste of
people's time then you get angry because
somebody else is denigrating the thing
that you're into if it's pet shows like
you know dog or cat or i guess you know
it could be any animal shows and
somebody comes along they're like wow
look at those idiots spending all that
money and time to get a dog to jump
through hoops and then everybody claps
what a what a load of crap right well
then you you get angry about that but
you get angry about that because you
take that seriously and you're looking
for some sort of
recognition or status with respect to
those matters
aristotle goes on and he notes a very
interesting aspect of this dynamic
people who are
really secure in these kinds of matters
don't really get angry about that
why not because they know
that they are
well off with it like he says
when they feel strongly they do possess
these qualities which are the subject of
mockery they pay no heed to it they're
not worried about what some random
person
some you know joe blow jackass has to
say
about the thing that they know better
about
it's when they're less secure
about it that they
become angry so aristotle says that they
become more angry
when they suspect that they don't really
have these things in greek quite
literally that these things aren't for
them
our toys
is to like be present to be available so
you know when it comes to philosophy
you're getting very prideful about it
but you actually don't know anything i
mean i see this all the time with people
who get
very into the idea of hegelianism
and they they want to make everything
hegelian and then people look at them
and they're like well you know hegel's
kind of outmoded
and uh got clearly got a lot of things
wrong and they're
so angry right and all they've actually
read is a little bit of the master slave
dialectic from the phenomenology they
made a stab at the preface but gave up
because it was too difficult for them
but they feel that there's something
there we can say this is too about
personal appearance right
if you
pride yourself or wish that you were
physically attractive
but you suspect you're really not
then if somebody comes along with some
stupid random insult let's say you have
acne and they say hey pizza face right
that was a very common thing back in my
childhood
people would get very ashamed about that
and angry and retaliate quite often you
say something back or push somebody into
a locker so they're more angry when they
suspect they don't have these things and
aristotle gives us a couple interesting
qualifications for it either not at all
holos right somebody who is
talking about their sports team and
they're some you know big pot-bellied
guy
sitting on the couch drinking beer
hasn't thrown you know a football for
years or picked up a hockey stick or
pick whatever else it is and they pride
themselves on their winning team right
when really
if they were to play they'd just be a
loser and they're uncoordinated they've
got nothing to offer but they can you
know talk about oh look at the new
uniforms ooh the referee made a bad call
well you know that's possessing it not
at all or if people are talking about
philosophy and don't understand
philosophy at all or
personal appearance
so maybe they don't have it at all or
not to any great extent
may
is
you know not strongly not forcefully you
could say would be another way of
translating this so you know they're
into
a certain genre of music but they're
really just an amateur and they don't
know that much about
its history
then you know somebody makes fun of it
they will get angrier as a result and
then aristotle points out one other
possibility or that they don't seem to
to others may
docate right they don't appear
to others to
be connected with to have
these these things there for them so
somebody who
wants to be
important and regarded as important in
philosophy and may actually have
something to offer
but is
not viewed so by other people
because perhaps they they just overlook
it or you know the class system within
academia pushes them to the bottom or
something like that well they can get
angry when their field is being
disparaged and this could apply like i
said to
any sort of fandom
that you think of any hobby
anything
that a person takes seriously it could
even pertain to things that are long
gone in the past you know i've got an
attachment to the roman empire and i
think caesar was such a cool guy and
somebody comes along and denigrates
caesar now i'm mad right
really quite silly and irrational isn't
it but aristotle points this out as a
very common dynamic that does in fact
govern anger and don't we see this
happening in our own life histories and
experiences and in the people around us
and in
the social media sphere and in
so many other
modes of we could call it social
observation and interaction i think that
he's on to something quite insightful
here
you